let's go to a next call at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 let's try the 3 8 6 area code call
her from 3 8 6 go ahead hi David
hi who's this my name is Giovanni I live
in Florida I'm a big fan of your joke I
find you through calculus joke who I
fronted through T YT and I love your
show and I love your videos thank you
for a fan I know I have a degree in
political science from the University of
Florida and I know you are political
science teacher up there in Boston
no I teach communication I don't teach
political communication I'm sorry but
still though we both love politics and
I'll be varying both special you can say
disastrous election last two years ago
absolutely are you gonna say you know
why do you think about YouTube you know
censoring and you know cutting up all
independent media I love you guys like
you want Kyle and humans are poor and
all others because punishment media just
keep reporting the same stupid things
like they've been going with the whole
stormy Daniels of air yeah they hoping I
think that may become more popular know
what what happened with Bill Clinton 20
years ago that cannot make it more
popular and they haven't really covered
issues that yeah that you know matter to
people look like if the facts of that
mean tax reform or look at you know all
the cutting it out of it defense
spending and now Trump is saying that
he's won the military for faithful to
all right so you know so what's your
question to you about me hmm what's your
question giovanni
re my question is what do you think
about you know him how are you for
living with all right how do you feel
about the establishment media is
reporting on the whole excessive donald
trump's that of I don't know reporting
on various issues that are gonna affect
people yeah well listen i crushed CNN
for this half hour just you know s show
debate that they had with Fermi Daniels
lawyer and Michael Cohen's lawyer I've
been super clear like that the stormy
Daniels story is relevant in so far as
the legality of the payments involved
and the possible pattern of using
non-disclosure agreements in possibly
coerced
to silence women that's the relevant
part Trump having an affair is not
really the relevant part our long
discussions are a distraction so big
picture I agree with you with the caveat
that there is validity to the story but
it's very very specific there's specific
elements that are the important ones of
that story okay thank you I agree with
your other question how do you feel
about jumbled tone now been on some
cabinet one thing I learned from Game of
Thrones - don't trust anyone with the
last name balke I don't know you watch
that show I don't I don't have my
reference but listen I mean I did a
whole rant at the beginning of the week
I'm against Bolton's a war monger and
he's bringing him in and it's just a
disaster Giovanni thank you really
appreciate the call great to hear from
our viewers down in Florida